this is the magnetic charging cable from
our sponsor mag team with the goal of
fixing the issue of having Tangled
knotted or just messed up charging
cables with this new magnetic feature
which allows it to basically hold onto
itself in different shapes and sizes
whatever you'd like you can customize it
yourself and basically have a much more
organized charging experience with your
devices we all know how much it sucks to
have knots like this in your cable which
actually phras rips and damages them
meaning you got to buy another one and
then you got to basically take the knot
apart and if you want to organize your
cable you basically usually kind of like
make a loop like this but then it comes
apart so you have to basically kind of
tie it into itself a couple of times
like this which terrible terrible
experience then when you're using it it
basically comes apart it's unorganized
it's loose it sucks there's other ones
like this where you have this little
clip that keeps it nice and organized
but then it's so annoying to basically
take the clip off like
this then you can use it you untie it
you have to take both Clips off then you
basically have to tie it up again put it
all in place this clip thing totally
sucks as well other Solutions you have
the braided cables where you also kind
of have to wrap it up like this but then
it sucks you have to unwrap takes time
it sucks with even these braided cables
and of course we have the solution of
having this little leather strap that
kind of straps it in but of course
you're wasting time with the strap
wrapping it up this is the best solution
from mag tame they have their o cable
version and their C cable where they
basically have a flat version where you
basically wrap it up coil it up like
this it's flat on the sides you can
unroll it you can roll it back up it's
always nice and neat then they also have
their o version which is Round And as
you can see look at that nice coil when
you take it apart you put it back in
place perfectly together look how
beautiful and organized this cable is
and the Magnetic function is actually
really impressive as you can see right
here I have a bunch of s card ejection
tools so I can just show you how easy it
is to pick them up with both the O
version and the C version there you go
the magnetic strength is actually quite
strong but check this out I have my
mofed wallet right here that connects to
my iPhone using Mac safe take a look at
this I'm literally holding up this
wallet with three credit cards in it
with the Mac tame cable the magnetic
strength is very strong and look I got a
Mac safe case right here so it's
actually got really strong magnet so you
can tell it's going to hold on just fine
to what itself which is awesome and as
you can see they have a bunch of
different versions you got usba a to
lightning you got a to c you got USBC to
lightning and USBC to C and both black
and silver versions as you can see right
here they actually look really nice and
the braid is very high quality as well
but here is my favorite part you could
basically change the shape of this to
any shape you'd like basically just
loosen it up like this and there you go
you have a big ger Loop like this or of
course you can tighten it down and put
it into a much tighter coil like this so
basically if you want a really really
compact cable you can make it small like
this fit it into your travel bag and
then let's say you have your hands full
I'm going to make it a little bit more
loose then you could basically just hang
it off your wrist whatever you're
grabbing taking it to your car leave it
like that I know it looks funny or it
sounds cheesy but honestly this could be
very helpful and then look how incred
inedibly tight I'm coiling up this o
version of the cable and just just look
at that look how nice that is so I love
that you can basically create any shape
you want to make but here is absolutely
my favorite part about these mag tame
cables let's say you want to charge two
devices and you want to keep them nice
and organized together basically grab
two of these stack them together like
this coil them up together and just like
that you have two cables connected which
means you can pick and choose what you
need right here I have USBC to see and
usba a to see for these two iPhone 15s
nicely organized change the shape
however you want to fit in your travel
bag plug it in and there you go look how
nice and clean that looks it's still
coiled up charging two phones at the
same time and then of course when you're
done simply unplug coil these two back
up like like this and there you go
nicely organized back into your suitcase
and if you want to why not just add
another coil right on top they're all
holding nicely together any moment take
it off keep them together this is by far
the best solution so with that said why
would you want to deal with this mess of
traditional cables that tangle that get
knots that rip Fray and get damaged for
you to have to buy another cable why not
just buy this right out of the gate have
a nice organized life you could do that
using the link down in the description
and pinned comment below definitely
check them out thanks for watching
subscribe above and we'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video